so if we want to reduce our carbon
footprint then we can either not use
electricity as much as possible or we
can try to replace something that's
inefficient with something that's more
efficient that does the same job but
uses less electricity in the example
we're going to use in this class as with
lightbulbs so we're gonna we're going to
learn a little bit about different types
of types of light bulb technology and
then we'll do some math problems on how
to calculate how much carbon you would
save by swapping out different types of
light bulbs so right now on the market
for consumer there's three basic types
of light bulbs there's the incandescent
the compact fluorescent and the
light-emitting diode also known as LEDs
okay so incandescent these things have
been around since the late 1800s these
are the of all the things in your house
that use electricity if you have an
incandescent light bulb it is the most
obsolete by far okay and the way it
works is that there's this little wire
in here called the filament it's made of
tungsten and the electricity flows
through this wire and it gets so hot
that it glows now it turns out they're
very very inefficient and you can think
of it as like a heater that happens to
make some light so if you go up to a 60
watt or a hundred watt light bulb or
even a 40 watt light bulb and you you
try to put your hand on it you can't
it's just it's too hot it's mostly just
making heat instead of light so if you
did the math which we're not going to do
it's like about one percent efficient so
if you put a hundred Watts in you're
getting one watt of light out and all
the rest is heat now pros they're very
cheap to make so like I know 25 cents a
piece or something like that and there's
a lot of people who think this is the
way light bulbs should look they like
the look of this style light bulb okay
but cons very very inefficient so then
and starting in the 40s people started
making 4s
lights and at first enter these long
tubes about eight feet long and then
people figure out how to miniaturize it
so that you can fit them in a small
socket and inside this this is a glass
tube that has a little tiny amount of
mercury in it like a milligram of
mercury and this funny white plastic
base here has a high voltage power
supply and what it does is when the
light goes on it excites the mercury
atoms and the electrons the outer
electrons in the mercury as they jump
back and forth between their different
orbitals and that produces light and
it's much more efficient than it make an
incandescent light bulb so this is a big
improvement over the incandescent lights
but the problem the problem is is that
it has a little bit of mercury mercury
is very poisonous as we learned in an
earlier lecture so when this bulb is
burned out you're not supposed to just
throw it away because if it goes in the
landfill and then the glass breaks and
then the mercury gets out and gets into
the groundwater
so disposal is a big problem with
compact fluorescents but they are more
efficient they use less electricity so
and by the way another con these
compacts have been around since the 70s
in the last decade they got pretty good
to where it was hard for most people to
even tell if you had one or not but the
early models were really ugly to look at
the light just didn't quite look right
there's a weird color now within the
last few years we're in the era of
light-emitting diodes and this has been
a huge revolution in lighting so in an
LED there's actual silicon chip it's the
same technology as a computer chip and
when the electricity flows through it it
produces light and how that happens is
pretty complicated we're just going to
kind of skip that part but inside here
there's a bunch of chips and they're
flat and they're in this case they're
they're lined up horizontally and
they're shooting the light straight up
so then what they do is they put a
diffuser on top to scatter the light in
all directions so that chip is called a
light-emitting diode so this
called the LED light they last a very
long time you can make them any color
they're very efficient if you see an LED
you put your hand on it it's it's barely
warm and they have been traditionally
LEDs have been very expensive to make
just in the last few years that's really
radically changed and now there's really
no excuse not to switch your bulbs over
to LEDs I mean I have a catalog from
like 20 years ago when one single LED
bulb is over a hundred dollars and now
you can get like three of them for 10
bucks at Home Depot and there there's
just tons of them out now this is what
an LED looks like if you were to take it
apart here's the little chips and
they're oriented so that they fire the
light comes perpendicular from the
surface so this one would be like a
spotlight light only goes in one
direction which is why they have to put
a diffuser on it to scatter the light in
all directions but they're coming out
with all kinds of things so for example
there are now these bulbs that have this
old-school light bulb appearance with
the filaments but the filaments
themselves are actually a little tiny
silicon chips they are a little tiny
versions of this that light up and you
can't tell the difference when they're
lit up I mean most people can't tell the
difference between the modern LEDs and
the old old-style Bowl Edison bulbs so
this is really changing lighting
technology so there's there are similar
stories with with a lot of the
technology in are in their homes so for
example 10 years ago a plasma television
65 inch plasma television used close to
800 watts now the same size television
using LEDs for the lighting eighty-eight
Watts right huge difference and all the
computers used more electricity or
refrigerators use more electricity we
could go on and on through all kinds of
technology but in this class what we're
going to do is we're going to do some
math with bulb replacements and it's the
same math that we've done before but
this time it's we're gonna swap out one
bulb for another okay so I'm going to do
an example of a bulb replacement type
problem and they're pretty
straightforward is just kind of common
sense you're going to do the
you're going to do the math with the old
bulb you're going to do the math of the
new bulb and subtract the differences
okay so let's say I've got a hundred
watt porch light and this thing is on
for 12 hours a day okay and I'm going to
replace it so this is incandescent right
I should I should have said that
incandescent I'm gonna replace this with
a 12 watt LED okay and I'm gonna my
usage is not going to change I'm just
gonna leave it on 24 hours a day no I'm
sorry 12 hours a day
okay so 100 watt light bulb incandescent
for 12 hours a day I swap it out with a
12 watt LED that makes the same amount
of light but it only uses 12 Watts 12
hours a day
how much do I save in a year that's the
question right so how much do I save in
a year and we can ask this question
several ways we could that could be coal
that could be co2 that could be money
okay so solve for the old bulb solve for
the new bulb subtract the difference
that's the easiest way to think about
this all right so the old bulb I got now
remember on these problems we got to get
to kilowatt hours before we can do
anything else so I'm gonna use my
energies power times time and I need to
figure out how much energy the old bulb
is gonna use in a year okay so in one
year
oops one year
I've got the 100 watt light bulb 12
hours a day hours times 365 and I'm just
gonna go ahead and divide by a thousand
to get it into kilowatt hours right away
so I take 100 times 12 times 365 divided
by a thousand and that gets me 438
kilowatt hours all right now if you
wanted to do it separate steps you could
I just kind of did an all one thing
there now this is the old bulb all right
the new bulb is 12 Watts 12 hours a day
365 days in the year and when I go ahead
and divide by a thousand to convert it
to kilowatt hours and twelve times
twelve times 365 divided by a thousand
equals 52 0.56 kilowatt hours okay so
here's the old here's the new right so I
can do this I can do this next math one
of several ways I will do it the way
that I think makes the most sense but if
you know what's going on you can you can
you can alter this method what I would
do to just make this easy as possible
let's say we're going to calculate how
much money we save right let's calculate
the amount of money we save from doing
this right the way to do this again more
than one wait but the way I'm going to
do it is figure out the amount for the
old bulb figure out the amount for the
new bulb and then subtract all right I
think that's the most straightforward
way of thinking about this so
the old bulb let's say we're charged 13
cents a kilowatt-hour right if I use
that number the old bulb 438 kilowatt
hours times 13 cents and the new bulb is
52 0.56 kilowatt hours times 13 cents
right so let's 438 times point one three
is fifty six dollars and ninety four
cents and the new bulb point 56 times
point one three is six dollars and
eighty three cents and then I'm going to
subtract the two so the difference is
$56 94 cents - six dollars 83 cents so
56 point ninety four minus six point
eight three is fifty dollars eleven
cents okay so this is how much money I
saved
so I calculated the dollars for the old
bulb the dollars from the new bulb
subtract the two okay same technique to
solve any other question if I asked okay
well how much coal did I save from this
it'd be the same way so let's let's just
do that let's say I have coal saved for
example the old bulb I go back to the
kilowatt hours I had four hundred
thirty-eight kilowatt hours and what's
doing pounds
okay how many pounds of coal is that is
2.2 pounds per kilowatt-hour do that
math for 38 times 2.2 is 960 3.6 pounds
that's the old one and then the new one
is 50 2.56 kilowatt hours 2.2 pounds per
kilowatt hour so I take 52 point five
six times two point two and I get a
hundred and fifteen point six pounds
that's the old one and if I wanna know
how much coal did I save how much coal
do I not have to burn now because I
replaced that one light bulb the coal
saved is the difference between those
which is 960 3.6 pounds minus one
hundred fifteen point six pounds and
nine sixty three point six minus one one
five point six is eight hundred and
forty eight pounds saved so one of the
themes here notice all he did is I took
one single light bulb and I replaced it
right that's it nothing else changed
except that one light bulb and by me
doing that I save 850 pounds of coal
every year so now imagine I did that to
all the bulbs in my house and now
imagine everybody else in the United
States does the same thing and what
happens is we start to realize you could
save so much coal that we could actually
shut off mini coal fire power plants
would we want to even need them that's
how much coal you could save by just
swapping light bulbs so once in a while
you might
see a billboard there used to be some in
town I haven't seen them in the while
and it talks about you know if every
person just were to change one light
bulb in their house then you know X
would happen that's actually true
because if there's 350 million of us in
the United States alone and we all just
replaced one light bulb then take that
number multiply it by 350 million
and suddenly you've got lots of coal
that you're saving from getting burning
going into the atmosphere